for the first time ever this week's
guest video uses art and animation
twelve-tone is a channel about music
theory that uses pen and paper and piano
notes and doodles of elephants but today
they're also talking about language
twelve-tone he welcome to 12 tone or to
put that another way okay that may have
sounded like a nice but strange melody
but it was actually a sentence in the
Lanka music I loon of her cell or the
universal musical language also known as
solar a soul solar cell was invented in
the mid 19th century by a French
musician named Jean Francois sudra who'd
become fascinated with the idea of a
language made of music his first attempt
which he called la telephony was fairly
straightforward he just took the French
alphabet and assigned each letter to a
musical note this wasn't really a new
language though it was more like a code
and it found its home where most codes
do the military Sutra tried to sell a
system to the French Army and later the
Navy but despite early interest they
never actually paid him for it he even
built a series of properly tuned cannons
in order to increase the volume of his
transmissions but to no avail still
though he wasn't about to give up on his
dream instead he set his sight on an
even more ambitious task a universal
second language his goal was to create a
language that was bound to no particular
country one that every person learned in
addition to their native tongue allowing
free communication across cultural
borders but just converting French into
a musical code wasn't good enough for
that Sutra was going to have to invent a
real language to do this he turned to a
system of musical notation known as
solfege this is that doremi stuff Dooley
Andrews was singing about well almost in
the Sound of Music the notes are doremi
facility dough which is the English
method but most other countries in
Europe use C instead and since sudra was
French that's what he did anyway having
so few possible syllables presents a
fairly obvious problem in English it's
hard to even guess how many single
syllable words there are but one
estimate I found puts it at roughly
seven thousand so every soul on the
other hand has seven these are reserved
for only the most basic elements of
communication like yes/no and and the
two syllable words aren't much better
there's 49 possible combinations used
for things like pronouns greetings and
common descriptors like good and bad
they're also used for conjugation soul
right soul can't fit a bunch of
different words for each verb so instead
it has one verb form the present and
then just uses a set of two syllable
words to tell you about the tense but
where things get really interesting are
the large
words which have the room to build in
some structures three syllable words are
loosely divided into groups of six based
on the first two notes words starting
with Sol si are based on fun and games
including run laughing and smile
words starting with Ray la on the other
hand are negative traits like
misanthropy distrust and intolerance at
four syllables he takes this concept to
a whole new level breaking all the words
up into seven groups called keys based
on their first syllable the key of dough
for instances all about humanity
including the body mind and spirit the
key of ray is four words about the
household and family me is for actions
and flaws foz for travel and war soul is
for art and science law is for industry
and si is for government there's also a
second set of keys that come up when
your word includes a note repeated twice
in a row although their meanings are
usually related to the main key and
that's it sutras language only went up
to four syllables with less than 3,000
total words the fifth syllable was left
open for future development in case new
words were needed but by carefully
removing things like synonyms tense in
parts of speech which are managed
exclusively through accents rather than
new words he managed to squeeze quite a
lot of meaning into just those 3,000
sadly will sutras work made him famous
at least in certain circles it never
repaid him for the time and money he put
into it to quote the writer Paul Collins
saw a soul is at heart the philanthropic
effort of an idealist and the
Brotherhood of mankind does not issue
quarterly dividend checks after sudras
death though his wife Josephine took up
the cause and the language started to
pick up steam with thousands of speakers
in a society for its preservation
founded in Paris culminating in 1902
with the publication of a guide to its
grammar by the head of the society bolus
las kievsky but the dream of a true
universal language was fading so
preservationist spoke Astana nother of
sudra selling points accessibility you
see Soros all doesn't actually have to
be based on music it's got seven
characters and can be grafted onto any
set of seven items like the seven
colours of the rainbow or more
importantly seven specific hand gestures
this meant that anyone who knew the
spoken language could easily learn it as
a sign language as well making it an
incredibly useful tool in communicating
with deaf people gave Sookie's guide
emphasized this possibility but there
was a problem at the time deaf education
in Europe was dominated by a philosophy
called oralism which is basically the
idea that deaf people should still learn
to speak and that teaching them sign
languages got in the way to be clear
this is no longer considered a
reasonable approach but forgave ski
event that the language he loved was
cut off from the people that could help
them most so who knows maybe of
turn-of-the-century educators in France
had been a bit more forward-thinking
we'd all be speaking in notes right now
probably not but maybe twelve-tone go
subscribe to them for more videos like
that one I would recommend starting with
their video about the Imperial March
from Star Wars next week
the last guest video which features a
Canadian